oh hi sorry you caught me reading my
book Church of cowards which comes out
tomorrow
very embarrassing that you caught me in
this organic unstaged moment where I
just happened to be reading this on
camera it is as I said does come out
tomorrow Church of cowards and you could
still pre-order it though go to Amazon
and get that pre-order now today let me
set that up there today we're gonna talk
about a few things we're gonna talk
first of all about the six hundred and
fifty year old communists who is about
to be the Democratic nominee and
conservatives are gleeful about it giddy
because they figure that a geriatric
socialist who has repeatedly publicly
fantasized about turning the United
States into Soviet Russia will be very
easy to beat and maybe he will be but I
have a word of caution that I'd like to
share with conservatives also the left's
campaign to sexualize children never
ceases man today we're going to talk
about one of the creepiest examples
we've yet seen this one courtesy of Pete
Buddha judge and I have five other news
stories worth knowing about plus I'll
explain why Clint Eastwood is officially
cancelled all of that coming up now
first Bernie Sanders Sanders won the
Nevada caucus which after Iowa and New
Hampshire puts them pretty much in the
driver's seat for the nomination with
the support he has in the ground game
the infrastructure you know it's hard to
see him losing the nomination at this
point unless a number of the other
candidates drop out before Super Tuesday
so that the anti Bernie vote can
coalesce around somebody like Buddha
judge but that's probably not going to
happen because these are all power
obsessed narcissists and they're gonna
stay until the bitter end so we see that
the echoes of 2016 with Trump with the
anti-trump vote in the primary being
split between several people allowing
Trump to coast to victory speaking of
2016 as I said I want to offer a word of
caution to conservatives because I am
seeing this excitement and and and
confidence as people on the right are
seemingly quite sure that Bernie will
lose in a landslide to Trump and I you
know I've seen people saying he's going
to lose you know he's gonna lose 40
stays or 45 states or whatever and I
understand that feeling I have felt it
myself I have myself said that there's
just no way you know there's no way most
Americans are gonna vote for a communist
no way it just isn't going to happen I
have said a lot of people are saying but
there are many things you know that I
thought Americans would never do and yet
have done in recent years and here we
are as a culture because of it I'm not
saying that I I think Bernie will beat
Trump I think the smart money is against
him but I am saying that he could win
and I think that his chances are
probably better than we want to think
and in fact you could make the argument
that he's Trump's toughest opponent so
let's think about this how did Trump win
in 2016
what happened because according to
everything we thought we knew about
American elections he should not have
won the people who were predicting that
he would lose myself included it's it's
it's not like it was irrational based on
everything we thought we knew he was
utterly despised by a large number of
Americans he had no governing experience
whatsoever he was a reality TV show host
there was even a tape of him talking
about grabbing women by the genitals
that came out just a few weeks before
the election
now that kind of stuff is supposed to
bury a candidate candidates have been
buried under you know scandals and and
and things much much less dramatic than
that but it didn't bury Trump why is
that well I think there are three
reasons number one he had a core of
extremely motivated and loyal supporters
who were very excited about him and in
as far as those supporters were
concerned it really didn't matter what
came out about him or what he did or
what he said number two he was running
against a widely despised opponent
number three he seized on the the moral
outrage that people felt in society
blue-collar workers against the elite
and people feel and you know the swamp
in DC people feeling taken advantage of
and so on well what do you know burn
Sanders has a core of extremely
motivated and loyal supporters and as
far as they're concerned it doesn't
matter you know we talk about all the
all the dirt and the oppo and so on
that's gonna come out about Bernie
Sanders in the next few few months yeah
I'm sure it will come out but as far as
the the people that go to the Bernie
rallies and are practically in tears of
adulation doesn't matter there's nothing
that could come out about him that's
gonna that's gonna dis wade then also
Bernie Sanders will be running against a
widely despised opponent and and in
Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders is all
about moral outrage so Bernie has these
ingredients as well and and he has them
authentically and what I mean is it's
not like he's trying to rip off Trump
he's not borrowing from Trump's playbook
like somebody like Bloomberg is futile e
this is this is who he is and what he's
been doing for decades do I think he's
going to win again no but I have you
know I really have no idea and neither
do you neither does anyone recent
history has shown us that you can't
really predict what's gonna happen when
you throw a person like Bernie Sanders
or like Donald Trump into the mix and
that's why conservatives who dismiss him
I think are making a mistake and I say
that as somebody who has dismissed him
as well because it's hard to it's hard
to to put to the side all the things we
thought we knew about the way politics
are supposed to work and it's also hard
to put to the side the fact that this
guy's a communist and so he really
should not win it would be crazy for him
to win but just because he shouldn't and
it's crazy doesn't mean it won't happen
now I want to focus on this third point
about Bernie the moral outrage this is
the most important thing I think to
understand about Bernie Sanders and
about leftism generally and so I think
we need to go deeper into this but first
a word from LifeLock you know tax season
can be a pain but when that's to put a
mildly of course but it's all worth it
when you open the mailbox and you see
that one envelope you've been waiting
for unless it turns out someone else
already filed your return which can
happen during tax season your personal
info like your name your social security
number may be emailed and shared more
than usual and every time you do that
you're opening yourself up
two bad things happen and criminals can
steal info from your devices they can
sell it on the dark web they can use it
to commit identity theft you need life
lock the number one most recognized
brand and identity that identity theft
protection life lock monitors for use of
your personal info they alert you to
possible suspicious activity and if you
become a victim of identity theft
they've also got a dedicated identity
restoration specialist team and they're
gonna work to help you fix the problem
so you know no one can prevent all
instances of identity theft or monitor
all transactions that are happening
everywhere but having life lock means
one last thing that you have to stress
about during tax season and there's
enough already as it is so join now and
save up to 25% off your first year just
go to life lock calm slash Walsh that's
life lock calm slash walls for 25% off
ok so Bernie Sanders
and this is the thing that I think we
just we need to understand about about
someone like Bernie and as I said
leftists in general he's making a moral
argument okay and that's what resonates
yes the unemployment rate is down the
stock market's doing fine and so when we
hear all these things from conservative
out of the economy is great and so Trump
is fine
yeah the traditional economic indicators
are good news for Trump but that stuff
doesn't really matter because there's
still an enormous amount of anger and
dissatisfaction out there and a deep
feeling of unfairness now whether we
think they those that should exist or
people should feel that way doesn't
matter they do and that's why Bernie
Sanders is resonating and that's why
Alexandria Kaiser Cortes is the biggest
star in politics there's a reason for
this Bernie Sanders is pointing to a
generation that is starting adult life
deep in debt from student loans and he's
pointing to the health care industry and
the fact that even people with insurance
are finding themselves bankrupted if
they actually have to you know go out
and get medical care and he's pointing
to income inequality and the
billionaires and their yachts and so on
and so forth and he's saying this is
morally wrong this this isn't right
that's his argument it's it's not an
economic argument it's just a moral one
that's all that's all he ever talks
about now yes I believe that his
prescriptions to fix these problems are
wrong but that's not the point the point
is that the problems exist and people
feel them and people are affected by
them and that's what's going to send
them to the voting booth and when
they're at the voting booth these are
the things they're thinking about now
I think conservatives need to have a
response to this that is more than just
oh shut up you're whiners you losers
you're snowflakes with your entitlement
mentality if that's our response we lose
okay and we deserve to I think I respond
to begin by recognizing the the
fundamental legitimacy of the moral
outrage that people feel about this
stuff because that you know they're
right it is completely unjust and
ridiculous for banks to be giving out
massive loans to kids who don't
understand what they're doing have no
income have no assets and you're gonna
go and let them sign up for a lifetime
of debt it's crazy it's unjust it's
wrong and it's unjust and ridiculous
that you know I have insurance health
insurance but we had flu going through
the house and so we needed to go and get
flu medicine for our kids including an
infant who could die from it and it was
$100 per bottle with insurance I got
four kids and this that's just one
anecdote people go through this stuff
all the time
and you find you know it's it's you
think well what's the point of the
frickin insurance what am i paying all
this money for and it's wrong you know
it is people are being taken advantage
of we have to acknowledge that if we
don't we lose and worse than then losing
we're also just wrong we've put
ourselves in the position of being wrong
so you know I've been saying this for
years
liberals make moral arguments what
conservatives so often do is they
counter with practical arguments and
guess which ideology has won the culture
and won my generation and thus already
won the future it's not the side that
always tries to speak to your wallet
it's the side that speaks to your heart
into your conscience this idea that
people vote based on their wallets I
don't know who came up with this
originally but they're wrong they're
flat-out wrong they don't understand how
people work which is interesting because
we're all people so we know we know what
actually motivates us on the most basic
and fundamental level it's not money
it's deeper than that
and if people feel like there's
injustice and there's things happen in
the world that are wrong you know that's
what's going to motivate them the most
and they're gonna be willing to make so
so even if you if you come and say well
yeah but if you'd if you know if you do
this if you if you try to solve the
problem this way it's it's it's it's not
the the best economic it's gonna be
there are all these economic problems
people are gonna respond to that and say
so what it's kind of the same thing that
pro-lifers say you know when we're
talking about the fact that we shouldn't
be killing babies and you hear the
response sometimes from people saying
well but if we don't if we don't have
abortions and then you're gonna have all
these unwanted pregnancies and you're
gonna you're gonna have all these poor
children they're gonna add to the
welfare rolls and eventually they're
gonna add to the unemployment rate and
so on and so forth
are those counter arguments convincing
to pro-lifers no because what do we say
we say so what that's not the point even
if you're right about that that doesn't
justify killing people so yes left isms
moral arguments are bad that's true but
the answer I don't think is to refuse to
engage on a moral level it's to counter
with better moral arguments you know I
don't know if you've noticed this but
this refrain that you always hear about
you can't you can't legislate morality I
know we can't talk about morality on a
public policy level because you can't
legislate more other who who are the
people saying that liberals don't say
that no this is these are these are this
is this this kind of weak sauce is what
you get from conservatives now the left
they used to say that because they
tricked conservatives this is what the
Left used to always say I can't
legislate morality can't legislate
morality and they tricked dumb
conservatives into believing that and so
now while the left is off legislating
morality conservatives are standing back
and say oh you can't can't no no no we
don't legislate morality well we don't
right as with the left told us we don't
well we can't think for our
but of course we do legislative ever
every piece of legislation is
legislating morality every law that has
ever been written anywhere in the world
in any country under any government
including ours is legislating morality
every single one because we make laws
based on what is right what we think is
the right thing to do everything that is
illegal is illegal primarily because we
believe it's wrong and you might say
well no it's it's illegal we only make
things illegal if it hurts people that's
why it's wrong to kill people okay but
what but but why should it be league II
be illegal to hurt people because it's
wrong to hurt people because it's
immoral
so at the bottom there's always morality
student loans as I said is perhaps maybe
the most important example of this as
far as the left goes Bernie's success so
far like it or not is due largely to
this issue disaffected young people who
are drowning in debt feel taken
advantage of they feel lied to and in
Bernie they see someone who not only
promises to take the debt away but also
just takes their situation seriously
whereas what they get from the right
mostly is shut up you're whiners the
problem with with with with Bernie's
solution though just like his solution
to everything else is that it is itself
immoral and it will only make the
problem he's trying to solve worse
Bernie wants to wave a magic wand and
forgive all the debt first of all that
isn't just a bailout of college grads
you're bailing out the universities who
take advantage of young people by
charging them these exorbitant rates
you're bailing out the politicians the
government which backs the irresponsible
loans given to to kids right out of high
school and in the meantime you're taking
money from people who don't have the
debt and you're forcing them to pay
other people's debt and then everyone
who didn't go to college in the first
place because they were trying to make
wise financial decisions and so they
sacrificed the college education because
they knew they couldn't afford it
didn't want to have all that debt and
they weren't gonna take that on now
you're making them into suckers you're
making them into losers so this solution
isn't just impractical it's not just
economically infeasible it's that it you
know it's it's wrong it's it's immoral
its unjust it's unfair and I think
that's the language and eat we need to
be using that's the point we need to be
making but then what is the solution
well this is something I want to get
into more deeply tomorrow there are a
few ideas that been proposed to address
the student loan crisis and the whole
issue of higher education a few ideas
that are much better more moral fairer
and more financially sound than what the
Socialists are suggesting as I say I
want to talk about that tomorrow because
it's a larger conversation but for now
suffice it to say that I think we need
to be addressing not just the past not
just the people who already have taken
out the loans but the future also we
need to find a way to stop the bleeding
we need to talk about how to put an end
to this entire absurd unsustainable
program of pushing kids into these
four-year institutions to get degrees
that most of them won't ever use and
won't need in the first place
so I have some ideas on that score as we
continue the conversation this week but
I'll talk about that tomorrow all right
coming up I want to talk about Pete
Buddha judges extremely creepy sexual
ization of a child which is something
that happened right on stage at one of
his rallies over the weekend but before
we get into that I want to run through
five other news stories worth knowing
about in a in a new segment that I'm
gonna call news took me a long time to
come up with that name this is why I'm
known as a creative genius number one
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez is being
criticized for wearing a designer dress
on the view on Friday cut some
conservatives on Twitter or have pointed
out that her dress
supposedly cost $500 $500 if you can
believe it look there are a lot of very
good reasons very good reasons to
criticize Alexandria Kaiser Cortes I
mean pretty much everything she says
provides you a reason but let's not be a
bunch of losers and get bent out of
shape because a woman who does a lot of
TV appearances spent a few bucks on a
dress I think there's a general rule
here when you're attacking somebody for
what they're wearing rather than from
for the ideas they're presenting you're
losing number two the Commandant of the
Marine Corps on Friday announced the
most important issues that Marines need
to address in the coming year and beyond
according to him those issues include
parental leave for adoptive same-sex
parents obviously a huge priority for
the Marines you know really important
stuff and also this is the most
important thing he wants to get more
women in the ranks so we have to
increase the number of women in the
Marines he says he wants at least 10
percent of of the ranks to be comprised
of women now let me ask you this
can anyone argue I mean can anyone with
a straight face argue that increasing
the number of women in the Marines will
help the Marines be a more effective and
lethal fighting force and if you can't
argue that if nobody can argue that then
what's the point of increasing the
number of women what's the point of
making any changes to the Marines that
are not in the service of helping it
become better at the one thing that we
need it to do well I understand the
point of course for the left the
fundamental purpose of every institution
in America is to advance cultural
leftism that's no institution can I have
any purpose higher than that number
three a sad story here a daredevil who
goes by the name Mad Mike Hughes died on
Saturday after shooting himself into the
air in a homemade rocket to prove that
the earth is flat and I'm not sure
exactly what the what the plan was I
guess the idea was to get really high up
in the air and take a picture of the
earth to show that it's flat I you know
I you could take a plane probably and do
the same thing but he crash-landed and
died you know I'm not gonna make any
jokes about a man's death there's a lot
of people have been doing online as you
can imagine what I do continue to find
it remarkable that
flat earther ISM exists remarkable until
I remember that the human capacity for
self-deception is basically limitless we
can convince ourselves to believe
anything really
and we're also storytellers you know
we're very good as as human beings one
of the best one of the things we're best
at is telling stories which is a very
important part of this because flat
earther ism is not a theory it's a story
so flat earthers have this whole story
they tell this myth they've constructed
about global conspiratorial conspiracies
but you know conspiracies anyway and
they made up this story and they tell it
to each other and because they find the
story interesting and compelling they
figure it must be true number four Mike
Bloomberg has been getting criticized
for having a bunch of women under NDA's
non-disclosure agreements now these are
women who have sued Bloomberg's company
for harassment and those sorts of things
but now they can't talk about their
experiences because they were made to
sign a contract binding them to silence
well Bloomberg now says he will release
three women from their NDA's if they ask
just three so this whole thing is
starting to really have the feel of a
hostage negotiation in fact I heard the
Bloomberg will release two more women if
the cop cars moved back another 500 feet
and five finally the biggest news of the
week of course of the year really of the
century is I don't know if I mentioned
this but my book Church of cowards
officially goes on sale tomorrow but you
can pre-order it now in Amazon otherwise
you could find it tomorrow wherever
books are sold or online of course okay
now speaking as we were before of making
the moral argument I believe the left's
sexual exploitation of children is one
of the great moral issues of our time
which is why I point to it and highlight
it quite frequently and I think this is
one thing that as conservatives we
should be talking about and exposing and
this is the kind of thing that motivates
voters people will go to the polls to
put a stop to this
it's it's the kind of thing that makes
people angry and they're gonna care more
about this than about the unemployment
rate and more importantly putting
politics aside we have a moral duty to
protect children so let's take a look at
the latest example of this exploitation
courtesy of mayor Pete Budaj at a
campaign rally over the weekend Budaj is
decided to pull a nine-year-old onstage
so that the nine-year-old could talk
about his sexuality and it's the kind of
thing you have to see to believe
watch this he says thank you for being
so brave would you help me tell the
world I'm gay too I want to be brave
like you well I don't think you need a
lot of advice from me on bravery you
seem pretty strong to see you
it took me a long time to figure out how
to tell even my best friend that I was
gay let alone to go out there and tell
the world and to see you willing to come
to terms with who you are in a room full
of a thousand people thousands of people
you've never met that's that's really
something so let me tell you let me tell
you a couple things that might be useful
the first thing is that it won't always
be easy but that's okay because you know
who you are and that's really important
because when you know who you are
you have a center of gravity that can
hold you together when all kinds of
chaos is happening around you that's the
first thing I want you to know the
second thing I want you to know is that
you will never know who's taking their
lead from you who's watching you and
deciding that they can be a little
braver because you have been brave nine
years old nine years old children at
nine years old haven't gone through
puberty yet they don't know who they are
or how they feel they don't have sexual
desires yet they don't know anything
about sex a nine year
doesn't have a sexual orientation so if
a nine-year-old tell you tells you that
he's gay you know we can we could talk
about the best way to handle that but
I'm very certain that the best way to
handle it is not to pull him on stage in
front of an audience on camera and have
them announce it to the world that you
don't do there is no good reason to do
it
and when I say no good reason good as in
no morally or ethically good reason it's
not gonna help the child there is no way
that it could possibly benefit the child
for him at the age of nine to publicly
announce his sexuality there's nothing
good that comes of it for him but of
course it's not about the child in this
case it's mainly about Pete creepy Pete
who has no compunction about exploiting
a child's emotional confusion for the
sake of winning a few brownie points
with the media and with voters and it's
also about as always trying to reshape
our our fundamental understanding of
childhood as a culture the forces of
evil in our culture they want us to see
children as people who have the
emotional and psychological capacity to
make profoundly important and
life-altering decisions for themselves
that's how they want us to see kids
decisions like declaring a sexual
orientation even if they haven't gone
through puberty yet decisions like
choosing a quote gender identity so in
the area of sex and gender at least the
left wants us to see children as people
who possess all the competence and self
knowledge of of adults now where do we
think this goes I mean do we think it
stops here do we think they say yeah
toddlers can choose their gender and and
third-graders can declare sexual
orientation in front of the entire world
but that's it that's as far as it goes
no more no further no of course not one
thing we've we've learned about
progressivism is that there's a reason
it's called progressivism it
aggresses progresses in the sense so
that that cancer progresses it keeps
going it keeps moving it keeps eating
away and in this case it's not a far
leap to go from here from very young
children and being able to decide a
gender and a sexual orientation to
arguing that children have the capacity
to consent sexually now I don't think
your average leftist right now today
necessarily in his mind
wants to legalize pedophilia I don't
think that I don't think he's thought it
through that much but I can say I can
predict that nearly every leftist who
today is arguing that three-year-olds
can choose their gender nearly all of
them ten years from now or even five
years from now will be arguing in favor
of legalizing pedophilia it is without
question the logical conclusion the end
point the last stop on this particular
train and and we will get there unless
of course the sane and decent among us
rise up finally in defense of our
children and put a stop to this madness
you know unless those of us who know
better can can actually respond we talk
about moral outrage we should you know
we need to respond with the appropriate
amount of moral outrage we should be
pissed furious when we see this kind of
thing when we see what Pete Buddha judge
did when we see that you know these kids
being taken advantage of by their
parents and three-year-old
three-year-old boys being told oh you
could be a girl
you know our response should not simply
be oh we disagree with that we should be
blind with anger because that's how
exploitative and evil and crazy this
stuff is but this is also
are to what the left does you know it's
all about normalization so they keep
shoving in our face over and over and
over again and eventually even if we
that what the hope the hope is that even
if we don't agree with it
we become desensitized to it and so we
throw up our hands and say hey I don't
like this but it's just the way it is
now moving on we can't we can't allow
that to happen
all right finally today debuting another
new segment on the show and in this
segment each day I will be cancelling
something or someone you know a lot of
people are critics of canceled culture
but I personally am a huge fan of it I'm
you know I love the idea anyway my only
problem with all the canceling is that
other people are doing it I think that I
should be the one deciding what's what
gets cancelled I have a lot of
experience hating things and so I feel
that I'm uniquely qualified to make
these decisions so today we'll start off
by canceling Clint Eastwood now in an
interview over the weekend Clint came
out in support of Mike Bloomberg for
president
throwing president Trump overboard
basically in fact Eastwood said that
that he's a little fed up with Trump and
he wishes that Trump would act quote in
a more genteel way without tweeting and
calling people names he said quote is a
real quote the best thing we could do is
just get Mike Bloomberg in there which
marks I believe the first time in
history that anyone has ever uttered
that sentence the best thing we could do
is get Mike Bloomberg in there but but
that is not likely nice what is canceled
I want to be clear personally I couldn't
care less who anyone in Hollywood
supports for president makes no
difference to me
Eastwood is cancelled finally for being
the most overrated director in Hollywood
this is a long time coming and the only
reason I'm canceling him now is that I'm
hoping that he now that he's dumped
Trump and gone to Bloomberg that
conservatives will stop pretending that
that you know his films are good because
I believe that's what's been going on
here we've all been pretending to like
his movies
because we have the idea that he's
conservative or Republican or whatever
now we can finally now we can we could
finally be honest if you go down
Eastwood's list of films that he's
directed now there are a few bright
spots in there but most of his
filmography is mediocre and sometimes
bad and in one case literally the worst
that film by the way is is the movie the
1517 to Paris that came out a couple
years ago Eastwood film directed it it's
about the four guys who stopped the
terrorist attack in 2015 on a train and
a very heroic moment you know and and
but also a moment that took about 30
seconds and so Eastwood tried to turn 30
seconds into a whole movie and he
actually hired the guys themselves the
actual real-life heroes he hired them to
play themselves in the movie now the
problem is that they're not actors and
as it turns out it does actually take
some skill to act even to act as
yourself you did it takes Talent which
unfortunately these guys didn't have so
it's the worst acting in a major
Hollywood film that I've ever seen in my
life to go along with some of the worst
writing and some of the worst pacing
that you'll ever see a monumentally bad
film but this has been Eastwood's mo of
late you know he takes a real-life
dramatic moment and he tries to turn it
into a whole movie even if there's not
enough of a story there Sulli he made up
he made a movie called Sully about Sully
Sullenberger landing the the plane in
the Hudson few years ago now another
very dramatic moment that took about two
minutes in real life which leaves you
with another about 100 minutes to fill
unfortunately there's just not a movie
there Million Dollar Baby
another bad movie where at the end Clint
Eastwood's character heroically kills
Hilary Swank because she's disabled
that's the end
it's supposed to be heartwarming him
performing a mercy killing on a disabled
woman is the end of the movie and it and
people are supposed to leave you know in
tears of joy at this at this beautiful
ending American sniper takes a
fascinating story of Chris Kyle the most
prolific sniper sniper in history
somehow manages to make a dull
repetitive
bland movie out of it that barely
scratches the psychological or emotional
surface of the man at the center of it
even Eastwood's good movies are
problematic mainly because Eastwood has
all the subtlety of a bag of hammers
falling out of the sky so you take
Richard Jewell for example I watch that
movie
pretty good movie important story but he
wants to make the point that the media
is irresponsible and reckless which is a
good point so he takes a real-life
reporter Kathy Scruggs and he turns her
into a cartoon avatar of an unscrupulous
ambulance chaser she's a she's portrayed
as essentially a sociopath with no
morals whatsoever who's happy when
people die openly happy when people die
and when tragedies happen because it
will make for a good story and it may be
true that the news media operates that
way but you know these are actual human
beings in the news media and human
beings are rarely so explicitly evil and
callous because humans have a deep need
to at least convince themselves that
they're decent virtuous people yet the
bad guys in this movie are just bad all
the way through no shades of grey
nothing human in them no nuance to their
personalities until the reporter who is
you know through the entire movie again
a sociopath a psychopath absurdly
cartoonishly evil the entire movie and
then out of nowhere and spent about 45
seconds she has a change of heart not
explained how did it happen
it just out of nowhere she becomes she
goes from a literal psychopath to a
compassionate humanitarian and at the
end of the movie she's she's she's
crying because she's she's so remorseful
about how she's been acting this is what
Clint Eastwood does his characters are
almost always lazily drawn
one-dimensional just there to sort of do
their job for the story you know hey I'm
the bad guy
yada yada evil stuff and it's just not
good and that's why clinics what is
canceled I'm sorry to do it but it had
to be done and that's it for for today I
don't know if I mentioned this but my
book Church of cowards goes on sale
tomorrow
so go order that to all of you who do
buy the book thank you
and I hope you have a great day to those
of you who do not buy the book you bring
shame on yourself and your family how
dare you and to everyone Godspeed the
Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2020 as Bernie Sanders racks up
victories all around the country
conservatives struggle with whether to
root for the radical socialist so Trump
can sweep all 57 States plus Greenland
in November or whether it would be
better to root for one of the also-rans
on the off-chance Bernie could somehow
win in November we will examine the
conservative case for Bernie then Pete
Buddha judge has a prepubescent boy come
out on stage at a campaign rally aoc
likes luxury for herself but not for
anyone else and so much more check it
out on the Michael no leo
[Music]